Gençler merhaba. 2026 senesini
noktaladık. 2027 senesine başlıyoruz.
Çok fazla soru geliyor. Hocam yeni
dönemde kitaplar değişecek mi? Videolar
değişecek mi? Nasıl bir rota
izleyeceğiz? Bunu konuşacağız. Ama bunu
konuşmadan önce 2026'yı bir
değerlendirmemiz, sınavlar hakkında bir
konuşmamız gerekiyor. Sınavlarda ne
farklı geldi? Önümüzdeki yıl için bunlar
bize ne söylüyor? Şimdi TYT yapıldı, AYT
yapıldı. Çıkan soruları gördük.
Öğrencilerimizle konuştuk. Fizik adına
konuşursam TYT her zamanki gibiydi.
Kavramları bileceksin. Bunlar arasındaki
ilişkileri bileceksin. Mevzunun
mantığını kavramış olacaksın. Bu
yeterli. Zor herhangi bir şey yoktu.
Yapılabilirdi. Tek sıkıntı soru
dağılımındaydı. Öz kütle bilgisiyle
yapılabilecek iki tane soru vardı. Zaten
toplam 7 soru var. Dolayısıyla ÖSYM'nin
işleri diyoruz. Geçiyoruz. Gelelim AYT
mevzusuna. AYT bittikten sonra
öğrencilerde en çok duyduğum kelime
hocam fizik bir değişikti. Şimdi ben
sorulara baktım. Zorlayıcı bir iki soru
sayabilirim. Genel anlamda aşırı zordu
diyebileceğim bir sınav değil ama
değişikti fikrine katılıyorum. Nedir
değişik olan? Geçmiş yıllara göre daha
çok sayıda sayısal soru vardı. Sadece
sayısal olması değil soru tarzı olarak
da klasik diyebileceğimiz, eskiye dönüş
diyebileceğimiz tarzda soru vardı. Bir
manyetik akı sorusu vardı ki sanırsın
2008 yılından fırlamış. Şimdi o manyetik
akı sorusunu sınavdan önce herhangi bir
öğrenciye göstersen bu sınavda çıkmaz
der çalışmaz. Çünkü son 45 yılın
sınavlarına baktığımız zaman eğilim o
tarz bir sorunun çıkmaması yönünde.
Fakat işte bir kez daha gördük. Eğilim
diye bir şey yok. Bu soru çıkar, bu soru
çıkmaz diyemezsiniz. ÖSYM'yi tahmin
edemezsiniz. ÖSYM'yi tahmin etmekle
uğraşmamalısınız. Kazanımlara
bakmalısınız. Sizden ne isteniyorsa onu
öğrenmelisiniz. Son yıllarda genel
eğilim öyle diye hep yorum sorusu gelir,
yorum sorusu gelir diye bir şey yok.
Kazanımlarda hesaplamalar yapar diye bir
sürü kazanım var. Manyetik akı sorusu
kazanımlara %100 uyan bir soruydu. Hatta
direkt buradan okuyorum size ilgili
yeri. Manyetik akı ve indüksiyon akımı
ile ilgili hesaplamalar yapar. E
yaptırdı işte formülü yazdırdı. Hatta
sinüsünü, kosinüsünü bile hesapladı. Bak
yanında bir şey daha var. İndüksiyon
akımı ile ilgili hesaplamalar yapar. Biz
hep ne buluyoruz ders çalışırken?
İndüksiyon akımı oluşur mu? Oluşursa
hangi yönde? Sağil kuralı falan. 2027'de
niye bir hesaplama indüksiyon akımı
sormasın? İndüksiyon akımı 3 amperdir, 5
amperdir diye sana hesaplama
yaptırabilir. Kazanımlar da var. O zaman
biz buna çalışmalıyız. Bu çıkmaz deyip
geçmemeliyiz. Hatta bakalım başka bir
şeye TYT için konuşalım. 9. sınıf
kazanımlarına geliyorum. Özkütleye
geliyorum. ÖSYM Özkütle sormayı çok
seviyor. Her sene sorar ama hep yorum
soruyor değil mi? Hiç hesap yaptırmıyor.
E bir okuyalım. Bir YouTube videomun
altına gelen yorumdan dolayı burayı
özellikle okuyorum. Yorum şöyleydi.
Hocam niye siz özle ile ilgili sayısal
soru çözüyorsunuz? Son yılların
sınavlarını inceleyin. Hiç sorulmuyor.
Evet bu öğrenci aklı son yılların
sınavlarını incelediğimde hiç sayısal
özkütle sorusu yok ama ben burayı
okuyorum. Düzgün geometrik şekilli
cisimlerden küp, dikdörtgenler, prizma,
silindir, küre ve şekli düzgün olmayan
cisimler için hacim hesapları yapılır.
Kütle, hacim, öz kütle arasındaki
matematiksel model çıkarılır.
Matematiksel hesaplamalar yapılır. Yani
2027 sınavında sana bir küre verse, onun
yarıçapını verse, bunun hacmini hesapla
dese, sonra sana oradan onun öz
kütlesini hesaplatabilir. Sayısal bir
sonuç buldurabilir. Bu bir kazanım.
Sınavda çıkmaz diyebileceğimiz bir şey
değil. Hocam TYT'de sormazlar da
diyemezsiniz. Eğer öyle derseniz
sordukları zaman da şaşırırsınız. Şimdi
bunu üstten üstten söylüyormuş gibi ben
size demiştim ya bak çalışmadınız ne
oldu şeklinde söylemiyorum. Sakın beni
yanlış anlamayın. Ben size mevzunun
özünü kavratmaya çalışıyorum. Biz
kazanımlar çerçevesinde fizik öğrenmeye
çalışıyoruz. Mantığımıza yatmayan hiçbir
şeyi öğrenmiyoruz. Bunlar işlemli soru
bakmıyoruz. Bunlar yorum sorusu bunlara
bakıyoruz diyemiyoruz. Çünkü bunlar ayrı
şeyler değil. Bunlar birbirinin
tamamlayıcısı. Konuyla ilgili işlem
yapamazsan yorum da yapamazsın.
Dolayısıyla işin mantığı, işin özü,
neden sonuç ilişkisi içinde öğrenilmeli.
ÖSYM'yi tahmin etmeyeceğiz. Ne yaparsa
yapsın hazırlıklı olacağız. Yani aslında
kazanımlar ne diyorsa onu yapacağız.
Bunun bir göstergesi de geçen seneki
dalgalar sorusuydu. Tek yarık sorusuydu.
Derste direkt bu cümleyi kurdum size.
Çift yarık deneyinde dalga deseni
oluşur. Aydınlık karanlıklar oluşur.
Çünkü iki yarık kaynaklar gibi davranır.
Ama tek yarık deneyinde de aydınlık
karanlık saçaklar oluşuyor. Bu iş nasıl
oluyor? Bunun peşine düştüğümüz için
2025 sınavındaki dalga sorusunu
yapabildik. Çünkü bu işe böyle
çalışılmalı. Bunlar detay değil. Bunlar
ayrıntı değil. Fizik böyle çalışılır ve
sınavda da hiçbir sürprizle
karşılaşılmaz. Şimdi gelelim 2027'ye.
Kitaplar değişecek mi hocam? Hayır,
değişmeyecek. Aynen devam ediyoruz.
Videolar yeniden çekilecek mi hocam?
Hayır, çekilmeyecek. Kanalda ne varsa
aynen devam edecek. Çünkü zaten hem o
kitaplar hem o videolar tamamen
kazanımlar ne istiyorsa ona göre
yazıldılar. Ona göre çekildiler. Kazanım
hesaplama yapar diyorsa hesaplama yaptı.
Kazanım matematiksel hesaplamalara
girilmez. Yorumla diyorsa matematiksel
hesaplara girmedik yorumladık. Kazanım
deney göster diyorsa deney gösterdik.
Simülasyon aç diyorsa simülasyon açtık.
Milli Eğitim ne istiyorsa biz de onu
yaptık. Atom fiziği ile ilgili yanlış
hatırlamıyorsam 67 videom var ve sağdan
soldan çok duydum. ÖyM'nin yıllardır
sormadığı bir şeyi niye bu kadar uzun
anlattınız? E çünkü anlat diyorlar.
2026'da atom modellerinden soru geldi.
Her ne kadar elektrik manyetizma sorusu
olsa da Milikan yağ damlası deneyinden
soru geldi. Biz Milikan yağ damlası
deneyini simülasyonuyla inceledik.
Oradaki fiziği inceledik. Oradaki
elektrik manyetizmayı da yaptık. Tekrar
söylüyorum. Bu bir ben demiştim videosu
değil. O amaçla çekmedim. Hem yeni
stüdyomu görün istedim hem de fizik
nasıl çalışılır, nasıl öğrenilir bir kez
daha hatırlayalım istedim. Kitaplar,
videolar aynen devam. Şimdiden alıp
videoları açıp başlayabilirsiniz.
Görüşürüz. Ken